the same agency that deals with national
disasters are heading to the border will
democrats change their tune
on the surge being a crisis of course
the e in fema
stands for emergency ron vitella former
acting immigration customs enforcement
director under president trump
former chief of the border patrol and
president obama sir welcome to our
coverage here and good morning to you
good morning bill greg abbott governor
of texas with maria on sunday
watch for the first two and a half
months of this year
they've made about 110 000
apprehensions including in those
apprehensions are
800 criminal aliens criminal aliens who
have
previously been arrested and exported
from the united states
78 sex offenders and 62 gang members
which include
ms-13 games i mean his comment went on
as well here's more numbers 78 000
counters in january
100 000 apprehensions including
encounters at port entries in february
new york times saying an additional 19
000 migrants with
adults and children have been caught by
border agents since the 1st of march all
right ron
what's it going to take well they took
the tools that were working last year
right in
on january 21st they stopped enrolling
people
in the migrant protection protocols they
sent a signal out to the globe and
certainly in this hemisphere that if you
bring your child
or you send your child to the border
that we're going to let them in
and that's what happens under the law
right these people the the children
are only supposed to be in portugal
custody long enough for them to be
processed
put into the system booked in if you
will and then moved on to hhs shelters
so so
the that workforce right now
unfortunately
are stressed out overwhelmed and they're
they're
it's backed up they have to get these
facilities right
they have to move these children into
hhs custody in 72 hours
and they're not able to do that because
we are encouraging as a country right
now we're encouraging
people to send or bring a child to the
border because
you're getting a free pass essentially
right that's what happened in 2014
the smugglers exploited the idea that we
were going to give children
a pass they called it a promiso that was
the humanitarian crisis under the obama
biden administration we've started to
abate that surge
by using family detention centers ice
put up family residential centers
so people could come in they could claim
asylum but they would stay in custody
until that asylum claim was heard that
deterred others from coming in 2018 and
2019 we did the same thing we did the
migrant protection protocols
with mexico uh historic unprecedented
support from the mexican government
allowing people to claim asylum at the
border but waiting in mexico again
that made people realize that they
weren't going to get
let in and so they stopped coming in
numbers and then on the 21st of january
quick i want to jump in here to your
point a moment ago we now know that
there's a backlog of over
3 000 children who haven't even been
filtered through the system yet they're
waiting
at or near the border to be processed
right now democrats are slamming former
president trump pretty hard they're
saying they inherited this crisis from
him much like they inherited
a vaccine crisis they said at the
beginning of the administration take a
listen to nancy pelosi i want to get
your reaction
this is a humanitarian challenge to all
of us
what the administration has inherited is
a broken system
at the border and they are working to
correct that in the children's interests
so this again is
a transition for what was wrong before
to what is ron does this ring true to
you
and is it a helpful argument to make at
this point does it matter
no it doesn't like if the system was to
be fixed
they would shore up the loopholes that
are in current immigration law that
wouldn't allow children
to be let in at the border and
inheriting what exactly
under the previous administration
title 42 these kids were sent back to
wait for their asylum claims either in
mexico
or into their home country um and so
that it wasn't
we didn't need the kind of shelter space
before january 20th because
there weren't large numbers of children
coming to the border and so
it wasn't broken it was actually working
the tools
that prevented the kind of surge that's
occurring now have been taken off the
table
that that wasn't done previous to this
administration that was done
starting january 20th ron thank you for
your time there's more coverage of this
over the weekend that you can see on
other outlets now and we've been on it
for some time but
clearly this situation has not slowed
and it needs
fema and possibly more to take care of
it ronda teller thank you sir
eight minutes past the hour